الناشط البيئي العراقي المعروف بجاسم
الاسدي مشاهدينا تعرض بالامس يوم السبت
للاختطاف على يد قوه مسلحه واقتيد الى
مكان مجهول وقال ناظم الاسد شقيق الناشط
المختطف ان قوه مسلحه اختطفت شقيقه قرب
العاصمه بغداد واقتادته الى جهه مجهوله
معنى من البصره شاكر عواد اهلا بك معنا
شاكر اذا ما تفاصيل لهذا الاختطاف ولماذا
يعتقد اخاه انه مختطف
بالحقيقه الامضاء متضاربه وحتى انه يعني
مصادر تقول انه اختطف قبل اربعه ايام ولما
احس المقربون منه انه في حاله خطره بداوا
بنشر
اختطافها عبر وسائل الاعلام او عبر منصات
التواصل الاجتماعي من اجل يعني الضغط على
القوه التي اختطفته لاطلاق صراحه هكذا
يعني الانباء تشير في الناصريه بعد انه تم
الاتصال باخيه
ويعني اعطى خيوط قليله عن احاديث الاختطاف
فقال انها قوه مسلحه اختطفته
بالقرب من مشارف بغداد يعني بين محافظه
واسط ومحافظه بغداد بالاضافه الى للمعلومه
بانه كان على وشك ان يستلم منصب رفيع
يشرف على اهوار التلمجله التي تقع بين
محافظه واسط والديوانيه يعني هذه كان قريب
على وشك ان يستلم هذا المنصب اي منصب وهل
هناك خلاف معروف حول هذا المنصب شاكر ربما
لحد الان
بانه هناك
يعني المقربون من جاسم الاسدي لا يريدون
صوره كبيره ربما يريدون ان يحافظون على
انقاذ لان كان حسب المصادر كان هناك تفاوض
مع القوه المسلحه من اجل اطلاق صراحه وهذا
ما عرفناه يعني من مصادر قريبه من عائله
الاسدي ولكن لغايه الان لم تتضح الرؤيه
حتى انه يعني الاختطاف كان قبل ثلاثه ايام
او اربعه ايام ولحد الان لم يعرف او لم
يتم تحديد من هي القوه او العائله تفاوضت
مع من اجل اطلاق سراح